By now, I think we all know about SpaceX and
Blue Origin’s ambitions to create a reliable
satellite internet service.
SpaceX has already launched thousands of starlink
satellites and they are currently in the process
of rolling out a beta version.
Meanwhile, Blue Origin/Amazon seems to be
years behind as they haven’t even reached
orbit yet.
Considering either company’s situations,
people love to make fun of Blue Origin for
making very minimal progress.
But what’s ironic though is that both SpaceX
and Blue Origin are decades late to the game
as Bill Gates was trying to launch his own
satellite internet service called Teledesic
way back in the early 1990s.
So, here’s the story of the time Bill Gates
tried to launch his own starlink but unfortunately
failed.
Teledesic was originally founded in June of
1990 by business mogul Craig McCaw.
Craig had previously hit it big with his company
McCaw Cellular which was a leader within the
cellular telephone market.
His father had actually founded the company
way back in 1966 as a cable television provider,
and though he did find a good amount of success
within that industry, it wasn’t till Craig
shifted the focus of the company to the cellular
market that they became a major player.
AT&T would end up buying McCaw Cellular for
$12.6 billion in 1993 making Craig a billionaire.
So clearly, Craig was not messing around when
it came to Teledesic.
He was previously able to identify an upcoming
boom within the cellular market which made
him a billionaire.
And now, he aimed to do the exact same thing
with the satellite internet market.
The first couple of years were pretty slow
as Craig was still very much focused on McCaw
Cellular.
But after the acquisition in 1993, Craig would
turn his full focus onto Teledesic and he
would onboard a notable partner which was
of course Bill Gates.
In 1994, both Craig and Bill Gates would invest
$5 million into the company and with that
Craig would begin to pitch his idea to countries
and companies around the world.
But wait a minute, both Craig and Bill were
billionaires with an abundance of connections
within the business world.
So, why did they need to raise money and bring
on investors?
Well, similar to Elon’s vision with Starlink
today, Craig’s vision was simply so massive
that even two billionaires couldn’t handle
it by themselves.
You see, Craig wasn’t looking to launch
10 or 20 satellites, no he wanted to launch
840 satellites into space.
At the time, this was more than the total
number of satellites in space.
And accordingly, it came with a hefty setup
cost of $9 billion.
Though the project was extremely expensive,
it promised to make internet access basically
universal.
No matter how remote a location was, it could
use teledesic’s service to contact people
in the city.
Given the company’s vision and the people
behind the company, many investors would give
the company a shot.
Boeing would pledge to invest up to $100 million.
Saud Prince Alwaleed Bin Talal would invest
$200 million and Motorola would invest a massive
$750 million.
Ironically, the company had no working product,
but it was able to raise nearly a billion
dollars mostly because Bill Gates and Craig
McCaw were involved.
Aside from raising a crap ton of money, Bill
and Craig were even able to convince governments
to set aside a portion of the electromagnetic
spectrum that would be exclusively used by
Tesledesic’s network.
Clearly, Bill and Craig were not messing around
and now, it was time to execute.
The duo was very much aware of how important
execution was, so they chose the best partner
they could which was of course Boeing.
Boeing was given most of the responsibility
of designing the satellites, building the
satellites, and launching the satellites.
Boeing already had extensive experience working
on space projects, so this project was a piece
of cake for them.
Teledesic’s proposed satellites were super
small and didn’t have to be launched that
far into space.
So, Boeing planned to simply launch clusters
of satellites on large existing boosters which
is not that different from Starlink missions
today.
While Boeing was working on deploying Teledesic’s
satellites, the relatively small Teledesic
team of 100 employees focused on getting regulatory
approval and hitting other technical requirements.
Everything seemed to be quickly progressing
forward, but this is when Teledesic would
face its first major setback.
As we previously discussed, Teledesic wanted
to launch 840 super small satellites, but
Boeing insisted on launching fewer larger
satellites.
Given that Boeing was Teledesic’s primary
contractor, Teledesic would agree and reduce
the proposed number of satellites to just
300.
The official explanation for this switch was
that Boeing’s proposed plan was superior
to Teledesics original idea.
However, a former employee of Teledesic would
eventually reveal in 2016 that this explanation
was a complete lie.
The primary reason Boeing insisted so heavily
on launching larger satellites is because
legacy satellite manufacturers already had
large satellites in inventory.
Now, manufacturing smaller satellites like
Telesdeic wanted wouldn’t be that hard for
them, but the manufacturers were heavily opposed
to this idea.
You see, these traditional satellite manufacturers
had a monopoly within the industry and it
was nearly impossible for a startup to compete
against them as the bar for entry was so high.
However, if these manufacturers expanded to
producing smaller satellites, the bar for
entry would be significantly lowered which
could lead to them losing market share to
startups.
Aside from this, the manufacturers were also
fearful that if they started to produce smaller
satellites, the US military would also prefer
to buy the smaller ones which had much lower
profit margins.
So, basically, Telesdesic was forced to switch
to larger satellites because satellite manufacturers
didn’t want to let go of their monopoly.
We’re not exactly sure how much these larger
satellites cost, but assuming that the cost
to launch all the satellites was constant
at $9 billion, each satellite cost approximately
$30 million.
To put this in perspective, Starlink satellites
are expected to cost $250,000 per satellite
and already cost less than $500,000 per satellite.
Now, starlink satellites are more comparable
to the smaller satellites Teledesic wanted
to launch, but even then the cost per satellite
is insanely high.
If we spread the $9 billion over 840 satellites,
we get nearly $11 million per satellite which
is over 20 times the cost of a starlink satellite
today.
And the truth is satellite costs have not
dropped 20 fold over the past two decades.
So, Teledesic was more or less getting ripped
off when it came to launching satellites.
Aside from getting ripped off, major red flags
started to pop up that people weren’t actually
that interested in a satellite based internet
service.
In 1999, two satellite companies named Iridium
communications and ICO would file for bankruptcy.
These guys weren’t targeting the satellite
internet market but they were targeting the
satellite phone market, but it clearly didn’t
work out too well for them.
At first glance, you might think that maybe
they ran out of funding or that investors
backed away; however, this was actually still
before the dotcom crash.
So, funding wasn’t that hard to secure.
The real problem with these companies was
that there was very little demand for their
services.
The only people buying their services were
people working fishing boats and people working
on oil rigs.
Let’s also keep in mind that during this
time period, having a cellphone connection
was a much higher priority than having an
internet connection.
So, if these cell phone companies couldn’t
find much demand, it was unlikely that Teledesic
would find much demand with the internet.
And this makes sense, providing internet access
to every corner of the world is a very noble
cause, but how many people living in rural
villages in the late 1990s wanted to access
the internet, had a device that could access
the internet, and could afford to pay for
a monthly internet subscription.
From an outside perspective, it’s pretty
clear why there was lackluster demand, but
Craig didn’t really see this side of the
picture.
In fact, he actually thought that the bankruptcies
of Iridium and ICO were great opportunities,
and he would spend the next couple of years
trying to acquire these two companies.
At one point, he would even invest $74.6 million
into Iridium to keep it afloat.
Clearly, the other investors of Teledesic
weren’t thrilled to see McCaw focusing on
keeping these random companies alive instead
of focusing on teledesic.
This would even lead to an investor filing
a lawsuit against McCaw for using Teledesic’s
resources to aid in his personal interest
in ICO.
Things were falling apart rapidly and Teledesic
was yet to even launch a single satellite,
and this is when the dotcom crash would happen.
Investors were losing millions of dollars
right and left, and they had no intention
of continuing to fund Teledesic.
Meanwhile, Bill Gates had just stepped down
from his role as Microsoft CEO and he was
looking to focus on philanthropy.
He really had no interest in trying to grow
another startup, so he didn’t do much to
save the company.
Fortunately though, Teledesic had not yet
locked in on a satellite contract with any
company.
They did originally work with Boeing, but
then they switched to Motorola and eventually
they switched to Thales Alenia Space.
And, ironically, their constant switching
would turn out to be a good thing.
Since they hadn’t locked into a contract
with any of these companies, they actually
still had a lot of the cash they raised.
Considering this unique situation, investors
would decide to pull the plug when they still
could.
And given the structure in which money is
raised for startups, early investors would
actually end up profiting from their investment
in Teledesic despite the company not doing
anything.
Late investors, however, would lose money,
but even those losses were quite minimal especially
compared to many companies that closed down
during the dotcom crash.
At the end of the day, Teledesic aimed to
revolutionize global internet, but honestly
it was just way too early as in decades too
early.
Combine this with the fact that Teledesic
didn’t have launch capability in house and
the fact that Teledesic was more of a side
project for McCaw and Gates, and it’s not
hard to see why the project never worked out.
It is, however, insane to think that these
two geniuses had the idea to basically launch
starlink 30 years ago.
Did you guys know about Teledesic?
Comment that down below.
Also drop a like if you guys are confident
that Starlink will have a much better fate.
And of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.